los vuelos a Moscú restringidos por un
ataque de drones ucranianos el
aeropuerto de nukovo uno de los más
importantes de la capital rusa limitó
sus actividades por varias horas ante la
detección de varios drones militares en
diversos distritos de la capital las
autoridades rusas afirman haber
derribado al menos cinco de estas
aeronaves no tripuladas y adjudican el
ataque a kiev a quien acusan de
perpetrar otro acto terrorista
el intento del régimen de kiev por
atacar una zona en la que se encuentran
infraestructuras civiles incluido el
aeropuerto que por cierto También recibe
vuelos extranjeros es un acto más de
terrorismo al mismo tiempo el gobierno
ucraniano reportó la muerte de tres
personas tras un bombardeo Ruso en la
ciudad de sumi los movimientos siguen
tanto en el campo de batalla como en la
arena diplomática el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin aprovechó su
participación en un foro de la
Organización de cooperación de Shanghai
para culpar a fuerzas externas por la
guerra
durante mucho tiempo fuerzas externas
han implementado un proyecto fuera de
nuestras fronteras para ser de nuestro
país vecino Ucrania prácticamente un
estado hostil antirruso y durante ocho
años Ucrania ha sido Armada hasta los
dientes
y en medio de la coyuntura la otan ha
decidido extender el mandato del actual
secretario general James toltenberg por
un año más líder de la alianza militar
desde 2014 y uno de los principales
partidarios del ingreso de Ucrania en el
bloque